it's weird isn't it because the these
opinions that as I say are fashionable
these are the opinions that will get you
booked on uh BBC panel shows that will
get you that will get you nominated for
awards in Edinburgh it's the opposite of
Brave it's the safest thing you can do
that's the weird thing about this
movement is they think they are
downtrodden they think they're The
Underdogs that's also why it's really
hard to push back against them you know
they are some of the most powerful
people in society they have prominence
in all major institutions be they public
institutions or or governmental
institutions Civic institutions they're
everywhere they're in the NHS the police
Academia I don't think that you can
seriously stand there and say that you
are a rebel that you are against the
establishment when all of major
corporations are on your side all of
Hollywood all of Academia the Duke and
Duchess of Sussex if these people are on
your side you are the establishment
and yet so much of their is about
being oppressed